[Music]
evolution is one of the main themes of
Godzilla and the monsterverse but is it
only seen in the Gman I mean this
Evolution tradeit now there are quite a
few monsters or Titans in the movies and
the Monarch series as well as the comics
that have been seen to undergo changes
which are different from their previous
scen forms but are they considered
evolutionary changes or is it just a
predetermined growth and development
stage following a preset life cycle here
in this video we will dive deep and
discuss this topic in detail and get to
the bottom of it all so let's get to it
firstly what is evolution in this
context it is in those gradual set of
changes that a species inherits over
countless Generations as a result of
point mutations in their DNA which
brings about bodily changes that helps
the creatures to procreate and survive
better better well here in the
monsterverse it isn't that rather it
diverts from the most scientific
explanation into the most scii popular
definition of the criteria which is a
set of changes an individual or a
specimen achieves as a result of
external and internal factors it's
simply transformation a metamorphosis or
transmutation but it's also more than
just that it is not yet defined in a
life cycle it is something unique and
kind of subconsciously achieved as well
so with this Define in short let's take
a look at which Titans fit the criteria
there are many different super species
and Titans in the monsterverse Titans
like Sila Rodan Methuselah Behemoth
Tiamat Nika Etc which will only seen in
specific instances and they don't seem
to change in appearance at all we can't
infer anything on these monsters since
there is no evidence for any changes in
them all that the monster ver shows us
is that they only have one type of form
now this brings us to the first titem
that we have seen changes on aside from
Godzilla that is titanas Kong the
question here is does Kong evolve we
have seen him as he was in 1973 as a
juvenile adolescent a bit more than 30 m
or 100 ft tall we then saw him again in
live action in GVK as a 337 ft tall
Titan and now in gxk he will grow a
longer beard having a silver back fur
and more muscle but does that indicate
Evolution well aside from the UN
imagable change in size from 100 to 337
ft in 50 years there is no trait that he
has incorporated in him that would
convince us that he has evolved in short
he only went through a simple growth a
cycle that any other primate would have
but it's just magnified 100 times so is
there a Titan that have changed
drastically in shape and form well there
is one and this is titanis mura or
otherwise known as the queen of the
monsters MRA we know she comes from an
egg and this egg would lay Dom for an
unspecified amount of time then when
it's time uh larva will come out and
over the course of a few days if the
need arises the lava will cocoon itself
and change into an Imago form which has
wings gigantic wings and godly Powers is
this Evolution it sure seems like it
right but no Mothra here is simply going
through a set of predetermined life
cycle phases to grow and mold into an
adult form and this process repeat over
all of her different
Generations okay so what about the ginin
musis do these mutos evolve at least uh
it's hard to say with this one though
the mutos have a crazy life cycle first
they grow as spes in a Titan's body
specifically a goira body then emerges
in their lavel form to find another
radiation Rich SCE to mature into a
sexual reproductive phase that is the
male Muto and the female mutos they can
then multiply in number with eggs that
seem to produce miniaturized fem and hwk
mutos then as they turn out in number as
they grow in population first and then
cause a mass extinction and then thin
out in Number the most hearty females
will develop into a queen and then the
last one that survives all of those will
become a prime a Muto Prime yet even
here there is a predetermined life cycle
path that cannot be broken they merely
change as they mature along the way with
powers that they develop or evolve as
they go through the stages so no mutos
don't really evolve they just go through
a set of predetermined phases seems
Bleak right are there any other Titan
that changes well amhuluk is different
he is only a brain with a telekinetic
nervous system so his body changes
constantly as the nervous system
accumulates Woody material but that's
barely an evolution it's simply hoarding
what about the Lesser super species then
the skull crawlers and the skull devil
right well even with these creatures
here the only changes we see is size and
the same can be infert through the
mother long legs the genitor Swarm and
the other Skull Island species so at the
end of it all we only have one monster
or a Titan that can actually change as
he wants to the only creature that
develops new abilities to counter his
enemies to make sure he overcomes a
similar life-threatening situation if it
ever arises again ever adapting and ever
growing and this is Godzilla the titanis
goira species so why does only Godzilla
evolve in a previous video we explained
the different Evolution forms that he
has and why he changes constantly in
detail in it we explain that Godzilla if
faced with a situation that is
life-threatening or he fights an enemy
that is physically Superior and somehow
he survives he would find a place to
rest to heal and absorb radiation and
then evolve different abilities and
features that would allow him to be
immune to such a similar threat if it
ever arises again and he needs a certain
type of radiation for this either
geothermal radiation nuclear bombs mous
life essence or for this new gxk ping
Zilla form he would absorb a unique ping
Hollow Earth radiation that would make
him change drastically from Blue Zilla
to pinkzilla so anyway here are the six
forms that Godzilla has already had in
the monsterverse at least the ones we
have seen first it is the 300 ft tall
1954 form second is the OG 2014 form
which is 355 ft thirdly the king of the
monsters uh the change form which has
grown to 393 ft or 120 m in height the
fourth form here is a Mothra assisted
burning Godzilla albeit it was a
temporary change the fifth form is the
GVK 1 that has more or less the same
with the kotm form but this one has more
energy output and it seems like there
was atomic energy that's seeping out of
every place in his body the last form
the sixth form here is the one that will
be seen in gxk the pinkzilla form which
has Crystal dorsal plates ping radiation
glow spikes on the tail and an overall
more athletic physique now is there a
seventh or an eighth form well the
future monsterverse flicks will reveal
new forms as the franchise continues
mainly to sell new
toys but there are one or two things
that we can tell you that is as yet
theoretical but it's possible Godzilla's
first ever pre- Tian form could also be
taken into consideration but we haven't
seen it yet this would be the
godzillasaurus of the monsterverse that
maybe a future movie or a series will
reveal to us something that may look
like dark of GVK and as we know titanis
duck is a cousin species of the goeras
the then lastly there is also the mega
goera form that one of the deceased
Hollow Earth goeras achieved the one
that was seen as a skeleton in the
throne room of the Kongs so that is
another form that we haven't seen but it
is in the continuity so all in all
Godzilla in the most of us could have
potentially eight different forms in
total or even more as time passes so
that's about it if you like this video
then watch this other one as well and do
check out our Channel as we might have
things that you haven't seen before for
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam